Can you have some confidence that you don't need a Syrex year if your inflammation labs are good?
So can you have some confidence that you don't need to do a Syrex
antibody test if your inflammation labs are good. So what are your inflammation markers?
So your inflammation markers would be elevated ferritin link I talked about before or
or elevated c-reactive protein would be elevated.
But the answer to that is no. So
because your elevation in your systemic
inflammation is going to be elevated every time you eat that food that you have sensitivity to.
It's very common that you can run labs on somebody that may have very bad gut issues and they have
really bad. Syrex 10 tests and they don't show
elevated c-reactive protein or paratimals or great indicators. That's more for
inflammation at cardiac inflammation. But now I say it as everybody needs to spend the money
at a Syrex 10. I'm not saying that either. I'm just saying that if
we want to do further investigation, that's a good test to do for further investigation.
You talk about where one of my sources of ill health, I'm trying to do all these things
right and maybe I'm not getting all the results that I want. But you know, you might be eating
all good foods. But if you have antibodies to some good healthy food that you're eating,
you are causing inflammation. You're causing ill health to your body. You can have inflammation.
You can have antibodies to spinach. You can have antibodies to broccoli. But broccoli is so good
for you and spinach is so good for you. But every time you eat it, you're causing inflammation.
So how do you know those things without testing for it? So if you're doing well and you're
feeling great and you're confident that you know, you're in remission and you're doing great,
then don't run a Syrex 10. I haven't run a Syrex 10 for a long time. But if you're not,
and you feel like you're going in the wrong direction, then you need to look in some
different directions for answers. So that would be a reason to run a test like that. So I do know
there's all these things cost money. So you've got to just weigh these things out.
The test if the cancer is aggressive or not. So you're talking about the signature test.
I wouldn't say that. I wouldn't say that the level of circulating tumor cells
equates to an aggressive cancer. What is the test that you could do to find out the aggressiveness
of a cancer? There isn't a test to know the aggressiveness of the cancer. The only test that the
only way you would rate the aggressiveness of the cancer is the growth over time. So if I had a
lump in my breast that was 1.3 centimeters round and two months later it was three centimeters round.
It doubled in size over two months. It's an aggressive, it's an in an aggressive growth pattern.
And then you did something different, I don't know, maybe chemo, maybe the right, maybe nutrition.
And two months later it was still three centimeters round. So there was no growth in two months
of that cancer that it's in a stable growth pattern. So is a cancer aggressive or not?
Any cancer can be aggressive at different times, any cancer can be stable at different times.
So how do you know that is by measuring over a course of time? That's the only way you know that.
So we've talked fairly recently. I feel like a million bucks, but I can't seem to shrink my breast
tumor. Maybe Cyrex would be useful, maybe, but if I apologize, I don't remember all the data in your
case. Again, if your tumor is three centimeters and six months earlier, it was three centimeters,
but I can't seem to shrink it. If it's not growing, it's not acting like cancer. So remember, cancer
is rapidly replicating cells. So if my tumor was three centimeters round, six months ago, a year ago,
it's not growing. And everything I'm doing is keeping it at bay, then it's not acting aggressive.
If it is growing slowly, it is getting bigger, then yeah, then maybe looking at are there other
sources of inflammation that are that are hindered, hindered my ability to kill this? Yes, that's
that's exactly what I'm saying is that you could look at different labs in different ways.
I'm going to look as there are other sources of inflammation that I may be eating good
times that I'm causing inflammation. That's why I gave you guys all access to the
chronic disease and autoimmune course to look at those videos. I know many people are busy and I get
it for once the rest of the week is getting more than you have to, but there's a lot of valuable
information that you could say, hey, this might help me with my fight against this disease too,
just because it has a label of autoimmune disease. Remember, in my book that I wrote, you know,
originally wrote back in 2010, I said cancer is an autoimmune disease. That's really is my belief.
It's tied to autoimmune factors. And I think if you can figure that out, I think that's going to
be a aid. I don't get it. I don't think everybody needs to do that, but I think that there can be a
lot of benefits to that if you feel like there's just a missing piece of the puzzle there.